let me let me bring up this mainstream
media stuff because someone actually
just chatted this and i had so i had the
new york times pulled up i want to go
through what the media has been saying
but this cnn article is one of the most
egregious violations of the truth
cnn writes kyle rittenhouse testifies he
knew joseph rosenbaum was unarmed when
he fatally shot him
that is completely immaterial
it it was a a a small second of this
massive trial and this is what the media
does they they pull snippets this is
also an interesting point though many
people thought it was crazy they put
kyle rittenhouse on the stand there were
a few points he made that could not have
been admitted as evidence unless he
testified and that's why people think
maybe maybe that's why they put him on
the stand one was that rosenbaum had
threatened his life on two occasions
and that he knew
that the ziminski guy was armed and he
testified he heard the gunshot as he was
running and turned
what this what the prosecutor is trying
to do
is falsely frame as much as possible now
i noticed a lot of people asking why the
defense wasn't objecting to the insane
questions of of the prosecutor
some have suggested
the prosecutor's line of questioning
were so absurd it's prejudicing the jury
against him
he kept asking the same question over he
has the same question like five times
and every time kyle would answer him
he'd say i'll ask you again
when you were going he was doing things
like you wanted to kill those people and
kyle goes i didn't want to kill anybody
and he goes i'll ask you again
you went out there because you wanted to
kill those people right and he goes i
didn't want to kill anybody he asked a
question again
over and over again yeah he was bringing
up video games uh he was trying to
inspire that video games are akin to
killing people no he said don't you play
call of duty with your friend dominic
black and he's like i mean maybe
sometimes and he goes and isn't the
point of that game to take these rifles
and kill people
and then he was like
video games aren't real life and then he
started talking about ar-15s being
prominent in the video game and and
kyle's like well there's a lot of other
firearms there's pistols and shotguns in
there as well but he was like but ar-15s
are the most prominent ones they're like
no
shovels and a lot of people a lot of
people are saying that it was almost as
if the term and concept of an ar-15 was
on trial since how much it was brought
up so how much it was talked about
let me show you how cnn frames this this
is not an opinion piece this is cnn's
factual news they say cal rittenhouse
testified wednesday that he acted in
self-defense when he fatally shot a man
who had thrown a plastic bag at him and
chased him last year in kenosha
wisconsin in what is likely to be a the
pivotal testimony of his homicide trial
quote i didn't do anything wrong i
defended myself he testified but in
cross-examination rittenhouse said that
he knew the man joseph rosenbaum was
unarmed when he ran at the teenager
right now said he pointed his rifle at
rosenbaum in an attempt to deter him
adding that he knew pointing a rifle at
someone is dangerous false that was
leading questions from the prosecution
the prosecution said did you point your
weapon at rosenbaum well yeah of course
he did and you did that because you
wanted him to know you would kill him
and you meant business and then kyle of
course like says i didn't want to kill
him i don't want anything he keeps
getting asked asked what what cnn is
doing is they're taking statements from
the prosecution that kyle either
passively agreed with or said i guess
and they're acting like he himself said
it quote he was chasing me i was alone
he threatened to kill me earlier that
night i didn't want to have to shoot him
i pointed it at him because he kept
running at me and i didn't want him to
chase me
you see they choose they select all of
the worst possible quotes from written
house he said that he feared rosenbaum
who did not touch his body at all that
night would take his gun and kill people
omitting the fact that the it was i
believe it was the medical uh forensics
uh medical examiner who said rosenbaum's
hand was on the gun and calvert nasu
said he grabbed my gun the prosecution
then said but he didn't touch your body
and kyle was like
right and now cnn takes that to falsely
frame exactly what happened let me pull
up this new york times real quick they
say key moments from kyle right now's
his testimony one of the things they say
thomas binger the lead prosecutor
pressed mr rittenhouse about why he
aimed a rifle at joseph rosenbaum who
had run toward him but was unarmed you
wanted him to get the message from you
that if you come any closer i'm going to
kill you that's why you pointed the gun
at him mr retina said he did not want to
kill mr rosenbaum though he believed
rosenbaum was trying to disarm him quote
if i would have let mr rosenbaum take my
firearm from me he would have used it
and killed me with it and probably
killed more people so respect to the new
york times for putting that quote in
right at the top yeah that was important
new york times julie bosman states gross
gross croots grassroots a paramedic from
west allis milwaukee suburb was shot in
their arm by rittenhouse she says that
he was holding a handgun pointed in the
air when rit house shot him from a short
distance away so that was that was at uh
she tweeted that at i copied it at 5 15
p.m then i tweeted at her you should
probably delete this and at 5 15 p.m she
deleted it well good right
but she tried to put it out there until
she was fact checked on it she wasn't
actually doing her job she was making
things up until the tweet started to go
viral and people were like why are you
lying there are two stages to this we
should absolutely criticize people who
are incompetent which is a large portion
of the twitterati the progressives and
the media when she puts out a false
statement like that that's very serious
so during the prosecution
during the trial
the prosecution wanted to bring up video
on an ipad and they wanted to pinch to
zoom and the defense objected saying
that apple's ipad uses artificial
intelligence 3d enhancing logarithms
to change the image and i tweeted out
that was insane and stupid because like
the
image interpolation is the very simple
thing
as you expand it a program uh machine
learning basically tries to fill in gaps
that are missing it's not 3d it's not
artificial intelligence that's still and
then people were like tim you're making
fun of boomers trying to explain
something and i was like okay i'll
delete it i'll do it i have no problem
um that people make mistakes and there's
a lot of journalists so you'll see a lot
of mistakes but we should absolutely
criticize if i said something wrong
people did and i said okay i'll accept
it when she puts out fake information
she'll accept it we should not we should
not tolerate it but we'll be nice about
when they do bad jobs will not won't we
they should not remain in those
positions if they're that bad but the
next degree is like cnn
falsely framing
select cherry picking quotes and
manipulating the narrative or npr
claiming that gross kreutz testified his
hands were in the air when he was shot
when he when he testified to the defense
that it was only after he pointed the
gun at rittenhouse that is egregious
when msnbc put out a video where they
say gross quotes testified his hands
were up then they show a clip of
something totally irrelevant that is
intentionally trying to manipulate
people that's the second level of that
jeffrey uh tuban was also on cnn jeffrey
tubin if you don't know who he is he's
the guy who spanked it to his co-workers
on zoom and he was on cnn and he
literally said uh
kyle is an idiot uh
which i i think is just i mean i mean
that's the type of level of commentary
you expect from cnn but still even it
when it happens it's still surprising to
to to see it as that blatantly out there
right in front of your face because
truly what they're doing is a huge
disservice and people who are paying
attention watching the trial are getting
a totally different perspective than
people who of course are just
editorializing and commenting about it
uh like tuban was i think kyle had a
hard time on the stand he he he answered
a lot of questions very very well so the
prosecution uh when the defense was was
was uh exactly was was doing the direct
with with uh kyle rittenhouse kyle of
course you know he's probably worked
this out with the defense answered the
questions he did a really good job he
explained you know why he was there what
his goals were when it came to
cross-examination with the prosecutor
the prosecutor was just badgering him
and badgering him and caught him up in a
few instances and now the new york times
says mr right now struggled to give
clear answers to questions about why he
brought his gun as he ran towards the
car lot with a fire extinguisher the
event that immediately preceded the
shooting of mr rosenbaum i'm watching
the testimony and he's and one of the
questions he asked was after the
protesters cleared away from this area
why did you walk directly in this
direction instead of going around them
and i'm like that's a question that can
only be asked in hindsight and kyle
didn't have a good answer because he
never thought about it and he's on the
spot and that's why it was a huge risk
to put him on the stand because that
question is garbage nonsensical he was
like why did you have your gun what were
you trying to be protected like he asked
him
why were you looking for ryan belch
and kyle was like because you're safer
in paris safer from who
and it's just like
kyle didn't have good answers for this
but
i think he's he's an 18 he's 18. he's
not experienced and this is why it's a
risk to put him on the stand if he was
sharper if he was quicker you know he
could have said something like because
there was rioters and arsonists and
people doing violence all over the place
because criminals exist because when you
go out on the streets for any reason
you're you're safer with another person
regardless of whether or not there's a
right or wrong so many of these
questions strike me as being in the same
vein of why did you wear that miniskirt
out at night young lady
so so one of the issues was when he was
asking kyle like why did you bring a gun
it's like
because someone might attack me who i
don't know and and kyle actually had a
really good answer he said you brought
the gun
the prosecution said to kyle asked him
why did you bring the gun and kyle says
i thought i needed protection and then
he said protection from whom and kyle
said something to the effect of i didn't
think i would need to use protection and
then the defense the prosecutor goes
i'm confused you said you needed
protection now you're saying you didn't
and kyle very quickly and very very
on point sharp said i thought i needed
to bring protection but i didn't think i
would need to use it
and that was really really good but when
you have a prosecutor who's asking the
same question 50 times right you now
give the media the opportunity to say he
couldn't answer
kyle kept was like getting confused and
saying i'm not understand i don't
understand your question one of the
things bingo said was that hollow point
bullets when they're fired into somebody
explode and kyle's like
what and the judge was like what like
what are you talking about
it seems like a gish gallop are you
familiar with the gish gallery i have
literally never heard that in my life
it's a debate tactic where you throw as
much garbage at someone so that they
look like they can't answer the question
properly so instead of asking questions
and debate like it's two plus two four
you go look two plus two equals five and
two plus two equals six and three minus
seven is twenty-two and you know it's 22
and now we have seven minus three is
four and your opponent goes
wait wait what did you say what and the
goal is to make you look confused to the
audience or
i don't know are these common tactics
generally speaking when doing a
cross-examination of witness like this
or is this specific to this case because
they don't have a real case and they're
trying to use these psychological
tactics well i mean i think they're just
phishing they're they're trying to throw
out as much as they can see what they
could get back i mean being
cross-examined like that for hours is
difficult it's it's not easy so i mean
just watching the case it really looked
like let's just let's just keep throwing
something at it let's see if we get
something back and you know if you're a
state prosecutor they're going to do
everything in their power they're going
to take as much time as they want to of
course try to beat up the the the
witness beat up the person being
questioned and and try to make try to
literally break them uh that's a tactic
used by many people in
cross-examinations just keep berating
them keep beating them keep asking them
the questions to see maybe it's an
interrogation tactic too to keep asking
the same question but in different forms
sure and you start you start off by
asking them like something that you know
is an affirmative did you do that yes
did you walk over here yes you get them
in the habit of saying i i have given
testimony under oath a number of times
depositions in court and whatnot and
with some lawyers you know in my mind i
know where they're going and i can
answer honestly and still sort of you
know screw with them and win the game
but i am not 18 years old i am not on
the stand fighting for my life i am not
being accused of murder that has got to
be an extraordinarily stressful
circumstance there's actually there was
an amazing point where they freeze frame
a moment
when he had when he went when gage gross
kreutz was attacking him
they freeze frame it and in the still
written ass's gun is pointed forward
towards the legs of gage gross kreutz
who gross creates everyone's name whose
hands are up and then he's like he's not
pointing a weapon at you but you're
pointing a weapon at him and then kyle
right now says
you've it's a freeze frame i believe if
you play the video you'll see i'm
actually lowering the weapon and i was
like wow like kyle actually did a pretty
good job on the stand however
it's the it's the james bond technique
if you ask a woman to in you know to
hook up 30 times this is literally the
james bond jokes from family guy ask the
woman 30 times and she says no once you
finally says yes james bond looks to the
camera and goes 30 knows and one yes
means yes
it's it's it was it's the james bond
joke but the point is that's what
abusers do
they know that they can ask you the
question 20 times until you finally get
confused and say what they need and then
they can put that on the record and then
go to the jury and say remember when he
testified x it's like yeah after you
asked the same question 50 times and
confused him that's a tactic they don't
have a case the crazy thing i'll say it
again was when the defense actually
stated to the judge that the prosecutors
either have forgotten the rulings of the
judge or are purposefully trying to
trigger a mistrial because they know
they have no case and they don't want
this to go before the jury the defense
actually said that to the judge
now what does it mean when they can can
they judge and we're not lawyers but can
the judge receive a motion and not rule
on it
so one of the things the judge said
they wrapped up
about i think like um eastern time 5 40
or so
the judge was actually contemplating
bringing another witness but he said
it's a little late you know why don't we
uh you come back tomorrow first thing in
the morning we'll dismiss the jury and
he said to the defense i'll get you my
preliminary no no
i i won't promise that but we'll see
what happens so i think the judge is
going to uh um
issue a ruling on the motion
but i'm not a lawyer i have no idea i
have no idea you're better off you know
listening to lawyer commentary that's
just what the judge said about a
preliminary ruling on it thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 pm don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time